UP NOTHIJO 'TY
PATRIOT TRYING TO OVEC EVIDENCE.
BUG E
AT'S THE SUBR UT VOTING RITS FE.
THINK ABOUT IT AS A DEVE
GUIDE TOEBUNKI LIEFIRST, REMEMB
AWOFOD JUDGES.
IN THE SIX MTHNCPITAE HAVE
EXTENSIVE FO A TO BACKES
AND THEY HAVE COMEWI
NINGUN.AT C
SPECIAL TEAN
FRAUDOF HRI THEEAD BEEN T
THE DEMOCR.G. INVESTIGATE
LIES. DEMANDED A
Y 3.3 MILLION VOTES OFFICIALS DU
CAST
SAVADA AAMNOEA
INVESTIGATION BY THE RLITERGIAPE
TIME AND THRMEDLECTION EXCAN H
1BALLOTS CAST.
M
TEVERNOR
D  BEEUTIDEN
DESPIT'SLIEUTENANT GYMT R HI
REPCA HASN'T ST
TRYING TEP CLAIMS
SHOWED THE RESULTS WER
ACCURATEEYE OF FIVE STATES
FRAUD-ITNGOUNCED
CA GRIFT
SGAS AN AUDIIT'S EVEN MORE ABSUR
AND  FRAUD.
A  BACK.OK AT THRE
AU AS AND
REPUBLICAN-LED INVGAT ES.
ANU' SEE T
THERE IS ONLTHE DESP KEEP DOT AE
NEBA ENOX NEWS
OF C O -T P G AM
SORRY RSDEAC
SHOULD RUSH  DEFEND.
AND THAT'S YOURECHECK.
>> JOHN, LE D A NUMBON TODAYIST
E  RS A
CIR POLLSTERHO T
R CT
B.S.